j welcome to the program how are you
today hey damn it's good to be back on
here how did this role come up for CBS
that's a good question you know i was
calling games for them in college
started last year when i finished up
playing and and then started doing some
side lying work after the college season
finished and for the NFL and there's a
couple of kicking plays that happened
and you know they just threw it down to
me on the sideline and I broke them down
and talked about why it happened how it
happened whether it was a blocked field
goal or a big return you know there's so
many things happen in the special teams
role in that realm that don't really get
explained to the casual viewer and I
think that's just something that they
said you know I think that's an area
that we can be a pioneer and bring
something to the Veer that they don't
really understand I think in this era
you have to have a good great
quarterback to make it to the Super Bowl
how important is it in the kicking game
well when you look at I brought up a
fact yesterday that over the last six
years kickers have been ninety-one
percent during the run during the
postseason compared to eighty four
percent in the regular season which is
pretty substantial when you look at how
big that gap is and I think it's because
guys are better I think there's two
reasons one the kickers are better in
the postseason for those teams if you
struggle during the season you're with
Terry you're going to lose games that
are close and miss kicks and that's
going to cost your team a lot of times
you don't make the playoffs the other
reason is you don't kick near as many
long field goals now that didn't that
didn't hold true in the dallas game the
dallas green bay game but for the most
part you're not attempting field goes
over 50 yards and you're the one
weakness with New England right now
Stephen Gostkowski you know and it goes
back to the AFC championship last year
he misses that extra point and really up
until that point he had been the best
kicker in the NFL for the last three
years but he misses that extra point
that plays a big impact on the outcome
of that game they have to go for two at
the end of the game they don't get it
and I think it had a big hangover effect
with him throughout this season because
he was not the same kicker this year and
he misses another extra point last night
and and now there's nine missed kicks on
the Year seven of them
right he's like a golfer just keeps
pushing the ball right well he has a
fade to his kick Jay is that he had a
little faint before but he has a big
he's got a fit like you said and you
know even to the point even the this
year halfway through the season we
struggled so much he moved over to the
left hash and extra points and just said
okay I'm going to try and play it and
I'll aimed on the left side and he'll
fade back and hopefully I don't slice it
enough but you know he keeps missing
those kicks right how important like you
know you get into your head I would
imagine it as a kicker maybe in it's
like golf but how much of a factor do
you think this plays in the super bowl
it's just like golf and you for sure can
get in your head you know and I spoke to
him throughout the season a little bit
and just gave him my thoughts and they
weren't anything revolutionary but
focusing on you know his fundamentals
and believe it in himself and trusting
than the guy that he's been for the last
ten years because you hit his career at
New England this is shocking but it's
better than Adam military's career at
New England now he hasn't had the big
kicks and the big moments in the Super
Bowls and the game-winning kicks but his
percentage is better his percentage in
the playoffs is 10 percentage points
better than Adam military's was in the
playoffs it's been a Terry better at
what he does than brady and what he does
that's a good question i think they're
both the best of all time at their
position you know I think Adam deserves
to be in the Hall of Fame and he's the
best of all time because of longevity
and sustained success and you look at
Tom and he's in his seven Super Bowl not
an opportunity to win his fist and you
know I think they're both going to go
down as the greatest at their position
of all time but the quarterback position
is so much harder than the kicking
position there's so much more that goes
into it and you have to be a leader you
have to go out there and you have to
manage your team not only on the field
but off of the field you know kicking
you just go out there and you do your
job you kick the ball yeah but he's won
two Super Bowls vintage Harry wanted
with kicks he did it you know and he
missed the kick in the carolina game
earlier in that game and he came back
and made the game-winner and then that's
why he's been the best kicker of all
time because in those clutch moments you
know the oakland game who
what happened is this Patriots team and
the dynasty if he doesn't make that 45
yard field goal in the snow and Oakland
I guess Oakland ideal and I bring that
up but it's the Tuck game the tuck rule
but never forget venit aryan addressing
snowstorm is kicking a 45-yarder to send
them to the Super Bowl I mean it that's
maybe a one in twenty kick you know at
that point I mean literally the greatest
kick in NFL history and then when you go
back and you look at the implications
that kick and what it started and then
he went he made one you know shorter one
and over time but you know even a
25-yard field goal and that smell is not
something easy to do these jay Feely
works for CBS they're kicking expert
former NFL kicker now you were with the
Players Association for a while right
fourteen years long time huh you're not
have a lot of conversations about that
over the years yes we did but when you
took this job at CBS then you you stop
doing that well I stopped being employed
by an NFL team and that's what's that's
my employment is my duty ravenna so yeah
but okay the is the active active player
is deflategate gone is it says Brady put
it in his rearview mirror not until he
wins was not game if he wins this is
that then we move past it or is it
always it's always going to be there
with him well I think people are always
going to bring it up because it's the
Patriots and because there's a history
and you know there's no question that
this game and this season is personal
for Tom Brady and you know just his
message to his parents and his sisters
after the game in the post game
interview with Tracy Wolfson there was a
lot that went into that and there was a
lot of emotion for him to step up on
that stage and to say that there was a
bunch of stuff on the internet that
we're saying that that was him you know
throwing shade at Aaron Rodgers it was
unquestionably he was acknowledging how
rough a year has been for his family you
know going through all of that offseason
all that stuff and an in suspension and
you know how personally they all take it
because they're such a tight family why
has it the Commissioner gone to New
England
I don't know he's scared to go there I
guess he can't avoid him any longer
though well yeah I could be awkward
there in Houston but it's a neutral site
though J it's a Doozer site there's
nothing but I'm ready would like more
though than the Commissioner having to
come up and present them with the Super
Bowl trophy and then maybe even the MVP
trophy how do you think Brady was
treated by the NFL it if it's different
if it's another name is he treated
differently now from a Players
Association perspective here obviously
well I could tell you from the player
Association perspective as well as my
own personal you know opinion you know
and I was in the judge's chambers there
and I think all along that it was unfair
and it was unjust and it was arbitrary
and they made a decision early on and
they didn't necessarily follow the
collective information they were trying
to justify their decision they didn't
understand what actually happened both
it's interesting because my son did his
science project Monsieur Dan on psi and
he wanted to see what happened to the
PSI and so at 0 degrees a ball went from
12.5 down to 9.5 in 30 minutes and at a
hundred degrees it went from 12.5 up to
15.5 so there's huge fluctuations in the
ball depending on you know what the
temperature is can you have your son
male his project here and I put it up in
the man can I will for sure do that when
he's finished now the pressure is on now
we've got to do a really good job of the
whole presentation cuz you know boys
well my girls do their project they're
beautiful [ __ ] named well my son does
astrologist sloppy and he just throws it
on there so I'm going to tell him you've
got to do a really good one now yeah i'm
just wondering about if how could this
have been handled differently where it's
a twenty-five-thousand-dollar fine or
that that we didn't get dragged through
this for a couple of years well they
could have handled it a number different
way they could have called the Patriots
before they AFC championship game and
said hey here's what's going on this is
over here make sure that nothing is
going on and it ended it never becomes
anything you know they could have just
handled it internally and find them and
said you know this is what the fine is
in the CBA for this infraction and it's
over with
and it doesn't become a big thing but
because of the way they did it the
cloak-and-dagger I think there was
people who wanted to catch the Patriot
you know I think that's what it comes
down to is their owner or his people I
don't know if his owners are I was
probably yeah I probably saves probably
other owners as well as people within
the league office that you know felt
like they have always flirted with the
rules and they wanted to catch him yeah
I got the feeling that it almost was
like Robert Kraft says look you can do
this to us as an organization and then
we'll move on and then the owners caught
wind of it and said wait wait wait wait
wait and then that's when the
investigation started whether that's
true or not that was always the feeling
I got because why would Robert Kraft
volunteer that unless he knew what the
answer was going to be with the
commissioner well and to me the whole
thing and the fact that we're talking
about it instead of talking about you
know how great he's played all year it's
just asinine you know you you go back
and you tell quarterbacks for ten years
you can do anything you want to the
footballs and so they do yeah you know
they do mud bath they take sandpaper
they do all kinds of stuff all week to
prepare those bones exactly the way they
want them and then the one day say we're
going to come in and we're going to hold
you accountable for preparing the balls
the way that you want them the best
holder you've ever had when you were
kicking was who I was going to say my
wife oh wait a minute here the best
soldier I ever had was radiant obably
was radiant agretti was pretty good yeah
he helped for me in college you know
that's all he did when we won the
national championship was withhold I'm
field goals which is just shocking to
think about how great he's becoming the
best of all time and you know he was
sitting on the sidelines watching that
season but yeah he was good older he was
always diligent you know he cared about
it he cared about his teammate Ross
Tucker was on last hour he said that
Brady greatest beer chugger ever I saw
that I everything i'm going to concur
with rod I don't think you shagging any
barrymore unless it's like a gluten-free
all organic was he first first team
all-big ten chugging while you were
there oh for sure why he does it all men
he does it all he's the most competitive
guy I've ever been around so whether it
was chugging
or is playing dominoes or you know
anything that he does golf whatever he
wants to beat the person that he's
playing against which is why it's so fun
to beat him you know that's one of the
greatest things ever is to beat him in a
game and just to make him mad well we'll
see if the Falcons can make you mad Jay
it's always great to talk to you thanks
for your insights as always and we'll
cross paths down the road thank you all
right then take it right that's Jay
Feely the kicking expert for CBS and Tom
Brady held for him in college the Dan
Patrick show weekday morning on audience
[Music]